the odd thing about when you're making a
movie like this Daniel you do hurt
yourself a lot like in the previous ones
what's happened to you I've had my right
shoulder reconstructed I have had this
left knee operated on my right knee
operated on a thumb hurts dry scalp
arena rot it's very difficult so you get
to do all the action of running around
and they mean that last time you did you
you you trained you're out there we've
got shot of you giving it your all here
you are look at that great she cares
sick Namie cares a lot more than that
lady there's the see he knows he's in it
she looks like why they thought when he
shot then you have a thing when you were
doing action stunts with her was that an
extra when you were doing the driving
I was yeah I had to drive into a crowd
of people and everybody all the extras
were supposed to like part like a C for
the car as you would do from a moving
vehicle coming in your direction and one
extra decided to just be a kamikaze and
just like dive in front of the car so I
almost ran him over which was absolutely
terrifying
was that a money-making scheme on his
part I don't know what was going through
his head but no I didn't hit him because
I have very good very good driving yeah
yes
yeah Christophe you weren't injured in
this film not on this one no no because
yes I'm tried to think you have any -
yeah yeah yeah yeah well you know you
get injured as you go along of course
you do but mostly psychologically
but was it Django Unchained with the
right a horse are you a natural horseman
and I think I'm more naturally a horse
than a horse
what hello okay if you say so good to
know I'll make a note I mean whatever I
will say now will top that thing so I
don't fret we'll just leave it at that
yes you're a horse
Oh God okay this is unbearable
hello ha cuz that's what you say it's
not Aloha Melissa's Aloha Aloha